you know one of the things we were
talking about 30 years of evolution of
the profession or almost 30 years of a
Evolution
um but one of the things that we still
see is that there is a huge amount of
successful breaches all the time
um
and um and I think um and one can ask so
what what are we doing as an industry
you know are we successful
um and and what can we do
um better or different and that's one of
those points of view that is that
Captain once again interested in the
profession
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
I'm so excited to be here today with
ofir zilberger who heads bdo's Global
cyber security practice for video
International working with BDO firms and
the cyber security leadership group to
develop and grow bdo's cyber security
practice around the world he heads BDO
Israel cyber security Center helping
organizations to manage their cyber
security risk and build their risk-based
defense his IIT and cyber security
experience spans over 25 years in which
he worked with organizations of various
Industries in size and geography with
c-suite and board members as well as
technology I.T and cyber security
leaders
of fear zelberger welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
thanks very much I'm great thanks how
are you it's awesome to be here with you
of your a few people have such a
an impressive background and a rigorous
journey in a specific field and domain
especially one that has emerged and has
you know transcended in such a
meaningful way as a part of our of our
society of our economics of our politics
of our social norms and this is of
course the cyber security space which is
a which is a fascinating one because of
its Evolution because of the challenges
that it presents still today and some of
the the ways that it happens and you've
had you know quite a quite a significant
arm on on the on the very Hands-On piece
of it on the on the advisory piece of it
on the high level thinking strategic
thinking but all the way down to the to
to the ground and to the really the
technical details and so today partner
ahead of video cyber of video Israel and
Global cyber leader video and really a
pleasure for me to pick your brain in
these 20 minutes and I'm excited to
learn is tell me first a little bit
about your own Journey from your
perspective and then I'd love to dive
into the evolution of of cyber from from
the way that you've perceived it
so um
um I I started my own Journey
um right in the right time so to speak
um it was just before internet became
commercial uh so right before we started
facing these challenges that we're
seeing today as hear challenges but in
the past you know they grew uh slowly
but surely
um and um I've had the opportunity to to
Really uh be a part of the people who
built the internet
um as an infrastructure and there's a
phenomena I would say of course uh you
know not in a very significant role but
I've had the pleasure of of really
experiencing things firsthand as the the
matures as they were developed or even
invented and that gave me um an
interesting perspective of this
profession I've been doing security
since 97
um so um Hands-On I could see the
um sort of evolution that that took
place
um so I started as a technical person
term and at a certain point in time I
joined one of the big consulting firms
learned how to take the technical
knowledge into a more business language
which requires a lot of in-depth
understanding of risk management which
is a very important foundation of our
profession today I'll get to that maybe
a bit later
and then I had the opportunity to
develop or to to start a company in
cyber security it was called information
security in the past and then another
company which led me to BDO who acquired
that company in 2016. so that's my own
Journey
um I think um to start with maybe um we
can touch this phenomenon of cyber
security in Israel I think you know as I
work with clients and organizations
around the world everyone knows that
cyber security is a sort of a phenomena
in Israel with a lot of innovation and
you know startup nation is not about
cyber but it is a part of that phenomena
and I think um when you look at the
Israeli ecosystem what's happening here
is really we see lots and lots of cyber
security related Innovation coming out
because a lot of people are dealing with
cyber security challenges whether it's
uh from uh security or defense
perspective or from an offense
perspective as they are part of the
intelligence corpse or the Army itself
and that happens in met in various
countries around the world
um this
um this um accelerated Innovation
development which is highly influenced
by um by the military here in Israel is
hitting the doors of clients if you can
imagine you know the largest banks in
Israel for instance they've been working
with him for with the startups that
present very innovative solutions very
early on and because cyber is such a
dynamic threat clients are not afraid of
using startup or even you know immature
technology to uh to help them with some
of those challenges what's happening
there is that the seesaws of these
organizations are getting more and more
mature in terms of solutions that
they're seeing out of the market and how
they can Implement Implement that those
Solutions The Regulators see that the
Consultants have to change is the
expertise of the clients sometimes and
that creates a whole lot of a sort of
self-feeding innovation Circle
um that everyone is involved with and
everyone is influencing and that's I
think one of the reasons why the Israeli
Innovation ecosystem is working very
well for uh for startups and also for
understanding you know the main
challenges and that's one of the reasons
why when you speak with Israeli
organizations to some extent you see a
higher level of maturity in information
security or cyber security in average of
course there are many organizations
around the world that have a lot of that
have a high level of maturity but is a
as an average I think this ecosystem is
quite too late
that's interesting and so from you yeah
you're tying in you know the whole the
way that the the country is unfolding a
lot of the different factors that are
that are pushing into it if you're
looking at the way that
cyber is is formed uh from a you know an
evolution of a category perspective do
you consider it a healthy Evolution do
you consider it you know how do you
perceive it now from the side looking
back sort of both from the from a
knowledge perspective a business
perspective a globalized perspective
how well did we do here
you know that the
um Security started really uh
in the 80s
um it started the before the internet
um became
um this um a significant phenomena
um
um with a with digital life all around
us
um we started out with very simple
things like you know making sure that
people have a password to access the
Mainframe uh or um set of permissions
that are appropriate to certain data
sets these these challenges have been
with us for a very long time
the internet brought huge amounts of new
challenges from technology perspective
and most of those were fairly new
technologies that the organizations even
though the technology themselves with
Technologies themselves like TCP for
instance have been there for quite a
long time organizations have never used
them definitely not in a commercial
sense universities had more experience
but you know the world start started to
adopt the internet in a very very fast
um accelerated motion and that created
huge amounts of challenges from a
technical perspective and those
challenges were thrown at the I.T people
in the beginning
I was that one of those I.T people with
network expertise and operating systems
expertise and all of a sudden you have
an internet gateway with a with a router
that connects you to the internet and
everything is exposed and then you need
to start realizing how you know I
remember the first time I was preached
or my network was breached I was a young
system administrator
and it was around 90 98 and someone it
was a very very simple way that they
they breached us it was purely technical
by the way it wasn't human based
um and that led us to understanding that
we needed a firewall before that we had
a firewall
um we had a very simple mechanism of
trying to sort out which communication
is allowed and which is not a firewall
is a tool that can do that for a bigger
scale organization
um with uh the appropriate policy that
is uh compatible with the dynamic
organization
um so in the beginning really the focus
was very technical there was no
governance there was no
um we didn't use risk management we
didn't use any of the methods that we
used today it was a sporadic and
dependent on technical people and that
was
um the case since around the internet
commercialization in 94.95 another way
to a very important point in time which
led to the second wave of evolution of
the profession
um that point in time he is the collapse
of Enron in 2002 three all that around
that time
um the the collapse of Enron and created
uh the need for new legislation which
was
um eventually called sucks sarban's
Oxley
um which is still very apparent today in
many of the things that organizations
are doing definitely in I.T but not only
in I.T
um and serbians actually started the
um
um a period of time of about 10 years in
which uh the main focus or even I would
say the only focus was compliance people
were very very
um
people were focused on being compliant
with servants Oxley to socks socks had
very strong teeth in terms of
um you know how a regulator or a
legislator can influence an organization
because it held
um with personal responsibility the CEO
and the CFO if they don't meet the
requirements and that's why every
organization was very busy with that and
what and that also led to a
a period of time where all of the
vendors that created Technology
Solutions for security sold those
solutions from a compliance perspective
or from a socks perspective now during
these 10 years between 20023 and up
until around 2012-13
um and maybe globally even longer
um by 2015 by the time we started
talking about cyber and not information
security and people were involved or
mostly focused on on being compliant now
the problem with compliance is that it
doesn't have anything to do with
Effectiveness it really has to do with
you know checking the Box do we have
that document on the shelf and it says
about whether we implemented the process
effectively although sucks does that in
many respects but in security because
it's such a detailed uh profession with
so much technical data and influence the
people that they were dealing with socks
were mostly engaged in implementing or
not actually implementing but making
sure that the controls socks controls
exist but the people who actually did
the day-to-day security were still the
technical people and they didn't and
there was a very big disconnect between
the compliance level that the
organization was reflecting out outbound
and the day-to-day operation that I.T
people did on their network uh you know
opening up a firewall rule or um
limiting us a server in terms of
functionality to make sure that it's
more secure all of that day-to-day
technology technical work was not really
connected to the level of compliance
that the organizations were reflecting
this created a huge gap between
insecurity in Practical security now the
reason why we haven't seen this Gap in
the early years you know 2002-3 and then
onwards until the end of that period is
because the threat levels were not
really
um There Yet the the threat actors that
we see are operating in the past 10
years since that beginning of the Cyber
domain or cyber world and up until today
um the threat level is so much higher
um and organizations are seeing real
business impacts which we haven't seen
in the past because the criminals were
not ready yet or not mature is mature
but those 10 years allow the criminals
to get a lot more maturity organizations
were lagging in terms of implementing
security so if you ask me a certain
level of or the third period of time in
that evolution is the the
period of time where we talk about cyber
is really about Effectiveness and less
about compliance and then there's also a
very important Phantom to make here
which is if you remember those
intelligence Corps or or military people
that um I was talking about before when
they got go out to the market they bring
some military thinking
um and the profession started with
Technical and compliance people but when
we started seeing critical mass of the
military thinkers
it infused into cyber
um business around the world and we're
seeing that in Israel but we're seeing
that in the U.S and in the UK and other
places as well
um
this created a fusion of two different
streams of development of the profession
one stream was focused on I.T business
risk and compliance and the other stream
was really involved with the information
Warfare it was about how do we hack into
terrorist organizations to understand
what they want to do or what are the
intentions how do we collect
intelligence and then these military
thinkers who were experts in offensive
security because of those needs to
collect intelligence Etc
um had a very interesting and unique
perspective on how to defend an
organization this infusion of these two
uh sort of um routes to to go the first
and the the military
Paradigm created the new
view or a new way of Defending
organizations and one example that is
quite practical uh and simple to
understand is you know if you feel if we
look at the back at the compliance
escape and one of the standards that
they are globally adopted in cyber
security ISO 27001 or in the past it was
it actually started as a pretty standard
with the number 7799 a long time ago
this standard didn't have the word
intelligence in it at all because it
wasn't part of the profession you know
in terms of how we thought about it in
the past today cyber intelligence is a
key element in any defense program and
intelligence is is a military thing
intelligence is something that the
military doesn't do anything without not
acquisition no not training and
definitely not any kind of operation so
we're seeing this Fusion between these
two professions today at a very high
level of maturity and I'm actually
curious about the next phase of
evolution that they will probably see
sometime in the next few years
that was so cool that was a really
really cool background I took I took a
lot of notes myself so thank you Phil
for that I I I'm coming from the Cyber
background and
and you vote you opened up new avenues
for me to consider as I look as a
reflect on what happened before I was in
the background right you thought you
took me all the way back to Enron
legislations sucks Effectiveness
compliance to today emerging challenges
um and and what's happening now I want
to leverage the last few minutes to get
to know you a little bit better because
obviously you've been thinking a lot
about this place for a long time and so
you're you're you're you're you're
interested in it you're you're living it
tell me why why what is it why why are
you so interested in the cyberspace over
the last 30 years
for me personally it was
um
it was based on
first of all my passion to technology
which was always there
um I had a very natural connection to
um let's say how it works for some
reason I don't know why and then my
biggest challenge throughout these long
years was to make to to create a way for
me to talk about technology with stock
management who uh usually if you look
back especially did not have any
internet background you know these older
people that were managing organizations
20 years ago when I was starting out my
career they didn't understand the
internet they did not understand the
threats and we had to speak with a
different language with them in order to
make sure that they both understand the
threat and also are
can support us in the challenges so one
of the things that I think kept me sort
of interested in the profession is is
this ability to uh to speak with talk
management to understand business
challenges and as a technical person it
took me a long time to to connect to the
business World properly and to
understand how you know business looks
like at a macro level from a CEO
perspective from a board perspective all
the way down to the CSO
um and I think one of the biggest
recommendations I can give
um in terms of how to really connect to
those business people is using risk
language risk is sort of like a common
denominator between different parts of
an organization and when you talk about
risk you actually talk about the
business you talk about what could go
wrong in financial terms or at least at
least in probability and qualitative
impact terms like high medium and low it
doesn't necessarily have to be you know
a Millions figure
and that creates once again a common
denominator in terms of language between
different parts of the organization and
you can start comparing the level of
risk that the different parts of the
organizations can be exposed to and also
you can start comparing different kinds
of risks and start priority prioritizing
those based on the level of risk that
the management Sees at each area you
know we talked about compliance for
instance
IC compliance is something that is a
very
significant risk for some organizations
definitely ones that can suffer a big
fine if they're not compliant or even go
out of business
because they are not meeting some sort
of a regulatory or other requirements
but compliance is a very different risk
from cyber security cyber is a risk that
can lead to huge impact a financial
impact or reputation and impact usually
compliance risk is less impactful from
from cyber risk but in any case those
are two different risks that need to be
managed separately
um I think um another point of view here
is uh
um in in terms of my interest with the
profession is really to
um help organizations make sure that
they build the right defenses
um and uh and and be resilient as much
as it as they can to to a cyber breach
um and you know one of the things we
were talking about 30 years of evolution
of the profession or almost 30 years of
evolution
um but one of the things that we still
see is that there is a huge amount of
successful breaches all the time
um
and um and I think um and one can ask so
what what are we doing as an industry
you know are we successful
um and uh and what can we do
um better or different and that's one of
those uh points of view that is that
kept him once again interested in the
profession
I am already inviting you to a whole
episode just on that on that topic
because 20 minutes is not nearly enough
and I have already a few pages of notes
here and and I really want to thank you
Phil for coming on and uh and uh it's so
clear how how meticulous you are and how
rigorous you've been thinking about
these things and the the journey that
you took me on is not just the Journey
of you know facts and figures but it's a
journey of deep understanding of the
different figures in the market the
factors of how these different
stakeholders are playing with and
against each other and then how
evolutionarily we've grown to understand
and the landscape and how different
players are interacting and and it's a
definitely conversation is going to
leave me thinking more so thank you
again for for coming on and being a part
of this show I look forward to sharing
it and I and I already am looking
forward to to our next episode talking
about tanja's ahead thank you so many
many thanks to you for inviting me it
was a great pleasure I'm looking forward
to our next conversation thank you Phil
thank you